(soft music)
(marker scratches)
(keyboard taps)
- Whenever I wanna come up
with a solution to a problem
and I don't have it,
my immediate reaction is to
go outside and go on a walk.
I love walking in all kinds of weather.
I feel like with the peace and calm,
moving away from the problem
and stepping away from it,
sometimes I get way better
ideas and it inspires me.
But, I also think there's
something to be said
about not being inspired.
Like, not always as amazing.
I feel like sometimes I
get struck with inspiration
for how I want to explain
a Khan Academy video
or how I wanna approach a piece of art
or how I want to approach a math problem,
but sometimes it doesn't come.
And so I feel like what
the best solution is
when you are trying to get
into that creative zone
and you can't, is just do it
and try to do something anyway.
Like write something or
write your equations,
try to figure it out.
And if you make mistakes, that's okay,
because it's something to jump off of
and sometimes seeing what you
already know down on paper
can help you come up with better ideas
and can help you be more creative.
- Forcing yourself to
just conjure a solution,
simply does not work.
Instead, take a break from the task.
Pick something else up,
like a physical sport or even video games.
And then come back to
the original problem.
That can do wonders.
(soft music)